rolling
hey what's going on it's Bill Burr and
it's time for the Thursday afternoon
just before Friday Monday Morning
podcast and I'm just checking in on you
the double point the double Point what
does that mean what does that mean does
it mean I just had too much coffee and
I'm overly excited or does it mean I
have a special guest
if you said all of the above you would
be right I just had a double espresso
one of the best flat whites I've ever
had and uh my guest this Thursday
afternoon is uh it's one of my favorite
stand-up comedians I don't know if I've
ever told you that I just think you're
before you [__] start talking with
your Midwest oh shucks horseshit from
Wisconsin from Wisconsin we got Nate
Craig who has a new uh special out
called live at the Green Mill gorgeously
shot special top-notch material you can
watch it for free on youtube.com
ATC please welcome
Nate Craig everybody Nate Craig double
points that's what it's all about also
caffeinated also caffeinated where do
you go man I was in my house I made me
uh man I didn't even get out of the
[__] house man I'm the only guy I
ever met
I'm the only guy I ever met got my own
coffee bean that's right we did we did a
gig a long time ago and we were just on
the road middle of nowhere some airport
somewhere and we just started doing this
redneck character that was just talking
[__] it was some dude in the airport
that I think I flew and I and when we
both landed I was like get this guy it
was just burned into my head I'm gonna
go only guy I ever met I'm the only guy
I ever met with anything I'm the only
guy I've met had a bass boat that went
through two counties just telling fairy
tales about himself the only guy I ever
met come on the guy I ever met I'll let
you know when I mean another that's
equal to my stature I love I who did I
see recently well I just saw someone was
like talking [__] just over nothing
that's when it's funny to me you know if
you actually really do something great
just shut up why would you talk [__]
about it that makes it even better like
when Barry Sanders would just break
everybody's ankle in the secondary sorry
Packers Fan score a touchdown and then
just hand the ball to the ref
like you know his wife told him to get
milk and eggs oh here you go honey just
that easy but if you sit there I feel
like and you know when you tug on your
jersey and you do that 300 yell for an
almost first down well then you also
yeah but you're also
pissing off the defense and they're
going to you know get a little B in
their Bonnet they're going to try a
little harder but when you when you act
like it isn't [__]
I feel it's demoralizing well so they
know more is common no offense taken
dude watching Barry Sanders run through
the Packers was that was some of the
most fun him and Randy Moss those are my
two he destroyed the Patriots so bad
like we never play them they're in the
NFC we play them once every three years
in his career he [__] us bet so bad
that it's it's part of his permanent
highlight reel we have a corner where he
faked him out so bad he was running in
the same direction as Barry he looks
over this shoulder Barry goes over there
looks over there he went like right by
him it was it was like an F1 pass well
the guy's trying to block it was just it
was useless yeah those are the best
though that's the easiest uh greatest of
all time argument in my mind what's that
running back
Barry Sanders Barry Sanders there's
nobody like Barry Barry Sanders played
on dog [__] teams for 10 years yes eight
straight two thousand yard season or
something like that couldn't take it
anymore it was just like play 10 years
rush for 15 000 and change and just
decided you know to walk away which was
the smart move now you've seen with like
CTE and I that was I was talking to
somebody about that like the all-time
rushing record by Emmett Smith is one of
the safest records like no one's ever
going to touch that you just don't get
the carries anymore nobody's doing that
yeah they turned them all into Roger
Craig
who was ahead of his time third down
backs receiving backs receiving back
possession running backs that's right
you gotta have hands like a wide
receiver now that's what I'm talking
about and that's what I always liked
about your comedy hands like a wide
receiver that's a great analogy Bell I'm
glad you said that no this you're like
dude like I'm telling you um any time
you open for me people always going oh
my God who you know how come I don't
know about this guy this is a guy you
have to know about like I'm not just
blowing smoke dude your whole style and
and the level of your comedy is I'm not
going to do this in 45 minutes if you're
going to be like uncomfortable here I'm
just like Beyond respect you as a
stand-up comedian
today I'll I'll take it okay today I
consider myself the most underrated
person with a special that's coming that
is out right now on youtube.com ATC Nate
Craig live at the Green Mill
um two specials my second ATC special
thank you for having me all right I'm
talking about we're selling this one I
know I know not your other franchise I
know this one's better because I mean
well you did it so I also this is this
is we taped it at the Green Mill that
you guys thank you this is awesome who's
the director because it's gorgeous
absolutely my buddy Hunters Connor Herms
is from Connor Hunter Connor's Herm is
that sounds like a first round wide
receiver that doesn't pan out
he said hi anytime a receiver has a
hyphenated last name he's gonna lie he
has or he already has like a [__]
torn meniscus that went undiagnosed
uh he's incredibly talented him and the
Director of Photography was uh Jack
Whaley both uh Madison Wisconsin guys
but came down winning just like Aaron
Rodgers well we got the Green Mill did I
ever tell you the special about how we
got the event because nobody's ever shot
there before if you haven't been in the
Green Mill it's incredible it's a famous
jazz club in Chicago it's founded in
1907 it's Capone's old spot he used to
escape from people trying to murder him
through the tunnel every [__] place
in [__] Chicago was Capone's old spot
yes anything in Kansas City I was in
Buffalo yeah Capone used to have this
place oh and we were in Peoria right he
used to come down to Peoria and that
Kansas City uh Peoria in Buffalo yeah I
played a an old Supper Club and they
were like I just wanted components
joints and you see they got the the
Escape [__] tunnels they had them
down there too and they were all like
bricked up that wasn't his writer that
guy's real estate portfolio if he had
just paid taxes on it yeah you hadn't
worn a condom he had to dig tunnels yeah
he did don't you want a vault no no no
no I don't so but this one's real bullet
holes in the wall the whole the whole
nine I mean it's incredible
um so we got to shoot there the uh I you
know I had I had ATC column and I think
he thought he's just like a like no
email kind of guy like he's just like
and and I think he thought he was
talking because movies shoot there uh
James con Thief that was shot there like
was that shot there yeah just watched
that movie yeah a few months ago yeah
yeah uh and and so like he's used to
he's used to big things trying to get a
hold of him and nobody's ever shot a
special there so I gave it to ATC I
think he thought he was talking to like
a network like a big you know big money
and he was Hollywood type [__] as
opposed to like you know like us with
this well I see what you're saying Nick
Greg everybody
well I mean in this day and age when the
you know the the writer's Guild is
striking for all the right reasons we
got to make the distinction between ATC
and your behemoths your corporate owned
behemoths and he thought he was talking
to one of those and he so he gave some
uh you know ridiculous price and and
Mike comes back to me like it's it's
it's it's too much I was like all right
well that's not a no but I had gotten
his phone number so I called him myself
I was like hey man I just want to let
you know Nate Craig not afraid to walk
up to the pretty girl in the bar nice so
you go back I'm not afraid to uh to
cross the line
and they got this show on Saturday which
is one of the best shows in America
paper paper machete it's called Saturday
afternoon show standing room only in
Chicago these people come out paper
machete yeah it's a live magazine for
mache
and so I called him and I was like hey
man I just want to let you know you know
I'm doing this special with Bill Burr's
company and shooting at your spot would
be a dream come true but if nothing more
I just want to let you know you got a
great show there on Saturdays the
producers are doing a great job your bar
is the best I've always loved it and he
goes through the middle of next year and
I just can't you know I just can't give
you guys a weekend anyway you can't do
it you know I got I gotta cancel my ex
and I know this night and I'm like yeah
no no I get it I get it it's just I'm
shooting this special and I'm gonna find
a place but I just want to let you know
sorry for bothering you I wanted to say
how much I respect you and your place
oh you're the guy
yeah yeah yeah no I would be it's it's
shooting my special oh you're the guy
yeah yeah it's my special oh well you
know I can give you an off night or
something like that I just can't cancel
all my other acts you know I could give
you like a Wednesday or Sunday I was
like can you give me Wednesday June 1st
he says I don't see why not
done deal came down came down from the
number he had given us 90 and just gave
it to me because because I was some
schmuck calling with that no you weren't
crossed the line and called him on his
cell phone
Wisconsin wholesome like you know what
his big move is when we go out on the
road together and we're in the midwest I
always say wait wait you know you gotta
sniff it out way around here is there a
good milkshake you gotta sniff it up no
no uh am I saying it right malt malt or
a milkshake no no malt malt it's got to
be malted because they don't do that on
the East Coast well also Custard in
Wisconsin it's that extra it's custard I
don't know about I'm not a custard you
gotta put eggs in it no no it's it's
just it's just you just got to go full
heart attack Gotta Go full blown Cardiac
Arrest buddy I gotta be honest I've been
doing this thing and yes I have lost
some weight thank you for not noticing
um your streamline Bill I'm not gonna
[__] you you're ready for the
Olympics before you before you do this
before before we get off milkshakes the
first time I ever works with you do you
remember this it was it was the week
your hot your roof caved in and we had I
mean we we were we knew each other we
weren't quite friends yet and we were
driving from Madison to Milwaukee and
your roof caves in and you're calling
your contact I'm sure you're calling
your wife and you were Furious and like
you I mean you were you threw at one
point I lost the car I went Ryan Leaf
dude you went Ryan Lee versus a beat
reporter and I'm like because my house
was literally collapsed washing down the
mountain and nobody that was home in the
house knew what to do yeah and I'm like
go up the [__] ladder [__] do
something like put a [__] bucket in
over the hole and something and they're
all like well I mean it's just the
water's wet and it's gonna get on the
ladder yeah and oh yeah that was water
was wet the water was wet that was okay
this is what the [__] happened oh this
still pisses me off oh no hold on let's
let's not go down so you get see that's
the thing you get I will [__] you get
whipped you if you spiral look so anyway
let's live in that house long story
short long story short I'm just we
there's there's no GPS I'm just pointing
exit here exit here you're [__] ah
and then you [__] address when you
get us to the honey get up the [__]
ladder and make something happen we go
to Cops Frozen Custard it's in
Brookfield there outside of Milwaukee we
go to cops pull over I order your
milkshake you're still yeah now you're
yelling at the contractor your mid
conversation I hand you the milkshake
and I just like go out and I'm like I
make a phone call or something I come
back you're like I know well no no no
and then you're like hey dude this
milkshake's fantastic yeah no no
obviously we're not do you remember that
at all do you remember no because it was
a blind rage now let me tell you what
happened let me tell you what happened
I'm surprised you remember anyway okay
we bought this great old house I love
old [__] it's a [__] disease to love
old [__] because it always needs to be
repaired so one of the front rooms
was Nia's office all right I love Nia
like
the best yes I just love her and it was
her office and I wanted it you know had
this awful [__] rug that somebody
stapled onto the hardwood floors from
you know in the 70s right you had also
got the floors done so you got the
floors done the roof caves in the rain's
going through the river so that's what
happened so I have the rugs taken up
that I get this [__] guy he he with
little the wood glue and whatever the
[__] it is dowels he he you know all the
Staples gets those all done Sands this
thing and just shellacks this thing it's
[__] gorgeous it's a beautiful warm
room creative space for my lovely wife
yes okay meanwhile of course you know I
buy the house it needs a new [__]
roof so whatever reason these old houses
they some of them uh don't this one did
not have like an attic it had more of a
crawl space
okay and uh there was a crawl space and
then there was like a hatch and you
could go up on to the roof we were up
there we used to watch the fireworks on
Fourth of July up there so for whatever
reason back in the day in the 1920s the
drain spouts you know they they they
have the corner of the roof right they
would lean it down like that and they
would drain into these spouts see spouts
for whatever reason they ran them into
the crawl space and then back out the
front of the house so there's this
precarious moment where all the water on
the roof for like
three feet goes down like a j trap
almost and then then like you see these
things coming outside the house it never
made any [__] sense so when these
guys just for looks I don't know why so
when these guys went to go redo the roof
they unhook the [__] thing and they
never they hook the other one back up
they never hook this one up you move the
gray headstones but you didn't move the
bodies the Poltergeist first [__]
rainstorm we have Niagara Falls it went
right into the house pulled collapsed
the ceiling all over that gorgeous
hardboard floor and kept going down oh
buddy into the the [__] bootleg
[__] this guy was like a
photographer there was like a developed
camera room in there or something I mean
I didn't give a [__] about that and it
was all all of this money I just I just
spent it and then I knew what those guys
were going to say they came over they go
oh Jay there's a problem right there
like you guys didn't know oh no we
hooked it back up there's nothing I just
said get the [__] out of here just get
the [__] out of here and that ended up
turning into redoing that room and then
having then remodeling that ended up
turning into like a [__] year and a
half of my life
and my first time dealing with
contractors where they're great about
showing up the first day and gutting
your house and then you're [__] and
then they get on with the 17 other jobs
they have you and it's always like today
we're installing this and then they
install it next is that all right well
when are we gonna do that I have to
order it it's like can you [__]
pre-order
because this is this is when you know
it's like a flip or like the Builder is
doing it
there's two houses in my neighborhood
that both started being redone okay one
of them is [__] done already the
other one looks like they just started
[__] three months ago and that's the
difference between a private person
hired a contract as opposed to a guy
that flips houses for a [__] live
when they flip houses for a living it's
just Bam Bam Bam the contractors is
business yes and they [__] get those
things done in like you know 90 days and
these other things it's like 90 years so
that's what ended up happening
and then there was the uh oh my God then
it was the insurance companies and um I
I still had a mortgage in the the
insurance check came and it was made out
to me and my mortgage company I had to
sign the money over to them and then
they had to inspect each level to make
sure that I was spending the money on
the house and not just keeping it and
having a keg party because they [__]
everybody over
they [__] the entire country over and
they people were so upside down in their
houses they were like well what the
[__] the point of fixing this I'll
just go you know I'm never gonna make my
money back it didn't make sense so then
they grabbed you by the back of the neck
this was my insurance my insurance money
I paid the premium this bank has nothing
to do with it
and this is this is all of this [__]
that these politicians with red and blue
ties both sign off on because the
insurance companies and the banks would
put these [__] and keep them in [__]
oh keep them in [__] office so I had
to sign this [__] thing over like a
little kid when my my checking account
was balanced they should be asking me
for [__] tips rather than talking to
me like I'm some [__] eight-year-old
you know who just got a bag of candy and
you got to make sure you know I don't
eat it all in one sitting oh Nate why
would you bring you should have showed
up at that company with a bunch of guys
with clipboards
you wanna show us your books here hey
Citibank
it's it's like I never understood why
the meter kept running during that hole
housing crash
well actually during the pandemic why
they still gave themselves bonuses at
the end of the [__] year and nothing
happens
you would think
you would think that you know with the
ma how crazy they get over a joke that
somebody says or or or or a book that
comes out or a [__]
whatever some guy with a [__] AK
whatever the [__] those guns are does a
little rant on the thing like on
Instagram like how much they flip out
about oh my God what's happening to
America and then these [__]
could do whatever they want and then
give themselves a bonus
in the end like something I joke about
my podcast I always love like when
you're in the corporate world what you
always blame is the shareholders well
pressure from the shareholders but then
at the end of the year when they just
give themselves a hundred million dollar
bonus it's like what do the shareholders
think about that because that's all our
[__] money that you just stole a
bonus you just took it
I don't know no what are we talking
about we talking about standard
Specialists we're talking about your
crawl space that filled up like a car
you drove off a bridge and yes now we're
talking about my stand-up special no but
I hear you buddy I don't understand how
how we let them get away with it but
it's just easier to go after your you
know your neighbor than it is to go
after uh to find the uh it's a soft
Citibank software headquarters yeah good
luck getting into that
Industrial Park
well there was a guy
whose toupee was as orange as my beard
who claimed he was going to drain the
swamp remember that
It's the funniest thing ever to be neck
deep in the swamp that you're saying
you're gonna [__] oh and that goes
for Biden too and then there's no
pirates in politics here buddy well to
be fair they wouldn't let him in the
swamp after a while they wouldn't nobody
would loan them money anymore well
that's the thing
yeah that's the thing you declare
bankruptcy enough [__] times yeah but
he's great but you're only the only
options
it's great at business that guy is great
at business he wrote the book
he wrote the book
I'll tell you you know what when they
put his name on a hotel though that
places the [__] and liberals have to get
over that too you understand he's not in
there and he doesn't own the hotel he's
like a Kardashian he didn't even get a
good brand he didn't even get a good
good deal on the sign that's
I think the TR I like the Trump sign
it's just like him it's blunt
it's not it's not scriptive it's just
Trump
[__] you or whatever I do love his
dancing I saw there was there was a
[__] oh my God
he gets the knees going I [__] love
that [__] I like that I love that he
sucks at dancing it totally has
confidence that's always I I there's a I
can't hate that part of them it's the
perfect dance for those crowds
dude it's a perfect dance for me no
don't if he's not hurting anybody he's
just dancing anything to keep from
moving your legs no he does move the
legs he's got a little [__] and he's got
a little like like knee thing that he
does so just kind of
it's like it's almost the Conan dance
the Conan dance he does it like this
with the the two Fists in the uh but I
will tell you this though he's gonna
stop doing it because once somebody said
it looks like he's given a double hand
job
I I'm calling he's going to stop because
I remembered I used to love when he did
this because I love the [__] dual
hand job [__] dance it's hilarious
but I always used to love when he would
do his show and he'd be like blah blah
blah back and forth you know what you
fired and he would go like that and
people started saying I don't know it's
like a cobra it's like snake then he
stopped doing it
he stopped doing it like he doesn't like
being like made fun of
like that you know yeah he's just pull
up a bastard man you just see the sad
childhood of No hugs with that guy yeah
yeah it's whatever I don't feel I don't
hitting kids against each other that
guy's the worst but here's what we need
this is what I'm thank God we replaced
him with a [__] warmonger with
dementia this that guy's the worst this
is what we need these no time out these
last two guys are the two worst people
that have ever been [__] president in
my life they neither one of them are
presidential material it's like a
[__] joke all right so we've both
elected a [__] jerk off all I want is
somebody sane in this next one like
Biden has to just put him in a [__]
home
that guy should be sitting on a porch
somewhere
yeah he can't even finish his speech to
him he clearly put sunglasses on him so
when he starts freaking out where he
doesn't know where he is that'll make
the stock market plunge he clearly knows
you can't have the president given a
basic speech about [__] whatever and
all of a sudden like he does get a scary
look in his eye when he goes up on his
lines but I he clearly knows his way
around the government I mean because he
gets legislation passed all I that's the
thing I can't handle he does yeah yeah
still that guy you think that that guy's
actually yeah remembering oh they just
got Sweden and NATO but I'm saying he
did that
um he did not do it I mean
I can't with you guys no no I'm not okay
you're like if you're going to sit there
and say Trump's a jerk off you can't sit
in and act like Biden no no they should
be driving anything
I never I never forgave him for votes
the Iraq War I'm not even gonna [__]
I'm not even gonna go there okay he's
your driver from LAX there is are you
looking at your phone are you [__]
looking at him the whole way
to make sure he doesn't take it down to
San Diego the good news is I don't think
you can press the gas pedal very hard
I the thing about oh he'd lie to you and
tell you that he could the thing about
this is what I need this is what I
really want I was last in my class and
putting my foot on the accelerator and
now I'm first out of this this is what I
want out of this Trump candidacy this
time around this is what we need as a
country because that's more dancing
everybody's saying DeSantis is cooked we
need who's is that the Florida guy the
Florida guy Florida man
we need Florida man to get enough of the
primary vote so that he overtakes Trump
a little bit and then Trump says that
the Republican primaries rigged and when
he does that everybody's gonna click in
their head they're gonna be like oh he's
doing this [__] again
I can't blame the Democrats this is
inside the Republican Party there's no
difference between them
I'm just saying keep it it may it
simplifies it Bill I'm just trying to
keep it in one yard if if he's if he's
saying that everything's rigged which is
horseshit
you don't you don't want to lose
elections don't nominate the most
hateable guy in the history of the
country
if he's saying everything's rigged it's
been I just it is
that I don't I don't think there's any
question that more people voted against
that guy what about that nobody voted
for about Bernie Sanders why are we
talking about this but how many times
does Bernie Sanders have to [__] win
the Democratic uh [__] nomination
they don't even give it to him I know I
know these are the Liberals yeah you got
it stolen from we gotta [__] it up with
the people
my heart breaks breaks the walrus
es they're [__] they're the same
people yeah there's I still like the
game of it if I have to if I have to
you know stomach it I want to see this
is what I want to see I want to see the
right play and the and let's get out of
hilarious I want to ask you this it's
going to be when Trump says that
DeSantis has rigged the primary watch
that that's fun why is Bill Walton's 30
for 30 as long as Michael Jordan's the
Last Dance wow is it I didn't even watch
it
I didn't watch it is it all narrated by
Bill Walton
yeah and it's just like how many times
did you take an elbow to the bridge of
your nose I didn't even watch it who can
reach who can reach his nose but it is
interesting I mean I don't want to get
on ginger on Ginger hate here this isn't
what it sounds like that's the direction
you're going
um
yeah I don't I don't know I just I I
have enough knees you're not a knees no
it wasn't it his feet feet knees
probably all the above I feel that guy I
feel like I went to you on the way to
Portland
when you get drafted by the Blazers
you're fine and on the way there
something happens to your knees or your
feet too much hiking there's something
about the the angle do they have a raked
sort of angle at the airport when you
land they got Topography is that what it
is they got they got a little they got a
little topography up there
stepping over all those tie-dyed
homeless people up there maybe
I mean dude they Bill Walton Sam Bowie
and uh the guy he never even played in
the NBA the the the guy from Ohio State
Greg Oden oh thank you nice Paul Aaron
yeah Odin yeah unreal the youngest like
what are the [__] odds every time
they get the number one pick yeah
yeah that's tough I would pull a Kobe
and be like I'm not playing there I'm
not going about I'm not going there
Something's Gonna there's something like
you know the Ghost Hunters show that
they always have you know when they try
to find the ghost they got to figure out
what's going on when you get drafted as
a big man
when the Portland Trailblazers have the
number one pick although uh big red got
him a championship he did do that
what about sabonis
sabonis was a nice big man underrated
that for that Portland they've had some
good Portland team beat those Lakers
those Kobe Shack Lakers five games out
of seven games that team was great they
had Steve Smith they had who else do
they have on that team yeah that team
was loaded and Vita sabonis down low
just dishing I mean he was doing
Globetrotter [__] it's big fun
right here this this year the NBA was
great I mean seeing the [__] nuggets
in there just something different that's
great I love it it's great nobody makes
he that guy yoke what's his name jokic
he makes that [__] basket he shoots
like he's throwing a paper airplane into
a football stadium that thing just lands
so effortlessly in the net I love
watching that guy play ball and he Pat
that team was loaded yeah it was a happy
no problem with the Nuggets championship
yeah I will say the way he moves I just
after a while I was going like is he
really faking people out with I mean he
he doesn't look like it's not smooth
it's not so it's very Larry Bird it's
not something where it's going in but it
doesn't look good I don't even know what
sport it looks like what sport does it
look like the only thing that we send
back and forth
which is I mean if they started showing
this on ESPN that [__] ping-pong dude
dude he sends me these clips and he goes
look what I did to you in the second
round of the Beijing whatever and these
[__] guys this is why you don't talk
to me anymore oh my god dude
that and the badminton [__] I'll tell
you there's two [__] Sports in Asia
right now that if they had
they had revolutionized Sports fandom
period the the [__] like dude these guys
are like 30 feet from the table nobody's
rigging a badminton game bam with with
the with the uh the uh what I love about
Badminton is the ultimate change up it's
coming at you like 200 miles an hour it
comes off the racket at like 140. and
then it's
falling to the Earth all soft and [__]
that's like in baseball the emergency
swing when you think you're guessing
fastball and it's a change up and you
got to do that and everybody in the
Dugout laughs at you like that is an
entire sport of that
like what do you just you just ride out
the speed until it gets to mid 70s
you're like all right I know what it's
doing why did racket Sports not take
over America
what's our problem bill
um what is the psychology it's always uh
no it's it's uh uh it's all just
marketing like the best [__]
doesn't always go to the what it is it's
the best thing that's marked whatever is
marketed my family had a badminton set
your fam the birds had a badminton set
God damn we did we did you had [__]
13 Brothers running around that house
you guys didn't have a badminton
tournament you know what I think killed
it is the object that you hit it's
called a birdie
it's the birdie and it's just like you
know you know America you know our
history this is Gangs of New York over
here this was a smash and grab all right
seven you can't let your [__] guard
down
if you start [__] playing a sport
that has birdie and you got the Kennedys
on one side and the Capone's on the
other you don't know what's gonna I need
to call it the [__] or the [__] or
something derogatory yeah
this guy yeah something like that
something something throw a little
misogyny in there and some little anger
a little hate well at the turn of the
last century the two you might lose but
you're still beating up this little
[__] right here right
well the turn of the last century the
two number one sports was boxing and and
horse racing
and then I think everybody got cars
so horses just I don't know I don't know
what happened to them they kind of fell
off
right and then baseball started coming
along and they were doing great and then
uh the White Sox fixed the 1919 World
Series they were in trouble and but then
fortunately Babe Ruth came along and
they literally built a stadium around
his skill set
[Music]
I will say that this is the only [__]
guy in the history of baseball literally
had a Stadium built around where it's a
base yeah there's this a photo I can't
find it I've saw it one time Aaron if
you can find this thing there is a
picture of the original right field wall
if you were backing up to [__] catch
the fly ball and you didn't know where
it was it would hit you the back of your
knees or mid thighs and you would have
fell over it when it was a little chain
link fence
I mean you would think that they had
daisies on the other side just keep off
the grass while we're re-growing the
grass that's what it was it's a booby
trap for anything yeah I'm just saying
it's just you know
This Is What It Is Well horse race I
mean that's interesting though I don't
think horse racing went away it's just
that there's more people and not all of
them have enough money to own horses or
bet on horses well I think back in the
day though like having a like a badass
horse was like having a badass car so
like my horse is better than your horse
let's have a race and it kind of
developed out of that [__] and then I
just think after a while it became my
car is better than your car so all the
super like the the Casual super wealthy
fan of it and it became sort of a
degenerate sport except for like the
Kentucky Derby or like the Preakness and
the majors you go to the majors
everybody dresses up and they act like
they care about their children right and
they're not here putting their [__]
tuition on the line on [__]
Seabiscuit or whatever right but then
like those other ones when you just go
to the train if you're going to the
track I mean it's almost like something
you don't
is it even legal in every state horse
racing
there's a track out in Pasadena right I
know that I don't think I don't remember
there being a horse track in Wisconsin
dog tracks Dog Tracks yeah yeah well
then also Peta came along and they're
like you know it was a thing
well yeah stop beating the [__] out of
the horses and stuff yeah there was so I
I don't understand people that get into
a line of business with animals and they
abuse the animals
you know I I get abusing the customers
people are [__] yeah treat your
horses right
oh yeah I would say uh oh yeah writers
are definitely Road hard and put up when
right as they say that's I don't
understand it at all that's why I
understand like the [__] comes out from
the studios like we're just gonna wait
them out until they start you know
getting kicked out of their Apartments
why are you in this business you want to
act like that go sell petroleum you
[__] what are you doing in this
business no it's we act like this is a
decent business every business is like
this a bill I'm not I don't have any
fantasies but at the same time I don't
understand why you wouldn't it's
undervalued like
the pat making the people that make your
product happy is just undervalued I
don't know how it went away they
separated themselves and it always went
they hired it was never there then what
happened was they had unions and
organized and there was a golden age
where you know you could get into a
union and you were protected you were
treated like a human being but then they
had power and then they abused it right
and United Artists yeah yeah no I'm just
no not even just in any industry you
know uh you know uh it's not my job you
know the classic The Stereotype of the
of the union guy is you know when you
deal with them is like you know you you
can't fire me we're gonna overcharge and
I'm gonna [__] not my job I'm on
break you know we're gonna get 10 guys
to do a job that takes two people I mean
they they finessed the system then the
rich people got sick of that and they
said well we're taking manufacturing
outside of this country now you and your
union guys have a good time because
we're out of here then that's what they
did and then they were able to go back
to this is what I think I'm might be Rob
this but they were able to go back to
how they treated the American workers
pre-unions which was like absolute dog
[__] and they had kids in there working
right so now their big guilt trip is
like
um hey stop treating those people like
that and then what they say is like well
if we don't have a child making your
t-shirt that t-shirt is now going to be
a hundred and fifty dollars it's like
why
when you used to make him here when I
was a kid it didn't cost that what
happened is they're not going to eat
into their they actually have to pay
somebody a decent wage you're going to
pay it not them
that's how I mean that's that's my
opinion no I agree with you and there's
examples of where it doesn't have to be
like that like that's why that's my big
Costco guy but I mean you know they're
you know
on the you fight the good fight I try
but I'm not I got again I got no
fantasies I understand is that the name
of your special fight the good fight no
live at the Green Mill live at the Green
Mill Top Gun 3 is the real title just to
reflect the energy I give off tune in
Maverick versus Alien versus Predator
now if you want to talk about corrupt
let's talk about the Chicago Blackhawks
dumping their whole [__] team with a
28 chance of getting yet another
generational player that's got them and
they got him and let me ask you and
you're all right with that I'm okay with
that you don't think that there was any
sort of underhanded Slip Sliding Away
moved his veterans out that was the
whole it's a new GM I keep [__] with
you it was it was an unbelievable move
and it paid off it paid off they
threaded the needle they got lucky but
so what are they going to do now they
got nobody around them Duncan Keith is
gone everybody's gone right they drafted
eight kids and you know it's got to get
worse before it gets better get worse
before it gets better but it could be
fun to watch even when it's bad
how big is that kid Conor I don't even
know I don't even know
I just I've never even seen him play I
don't even know if I've seen highlights
they got a Dave cimenko or somebody
there to Shadow him cover them so I'm
sure they got somebody they got somebody
back yeah Bob Probert Jr yeah yeah they
got to get somebody in there Bob Probert
rest his soul
um Bruins resigned lucich
yep 35 years old man God maybe the last
man on earth I would want to fight yeah
what I don't even I don't care how old
he is here's something I think if lucich
was on our team in 2019 I say we beat we
would have beat him in six arms behind
his back he could punch me he could
knock me out with his nose
break both my hands and then my face
with his face that is a tough man and I
am like he I just it's killed me all of
these years like I just became fans of
every team that he went to like the
amount of Calgary flame games that I
watched just to watch him play sure dude
how about what Matthew could chuck right
for the Panthers oh man Chuck did you
see this do you know he broke his
sternum he played that game he scored
the game tying goal yeah and then they
won and then pushed it to and then he
still played with a broken sternum they
had to put his they had to put his
clothes on I know and there's all these
people going oh these are the excuses oh
this is all the excuse no no no no no no
no no no no fat [__] no no no no no no
it's like just something for you to
admire yeah played two Stanley Cup games
with a broken I cannot imagine and then
somehow LeBron or LeBron gets [__] yeah
I like to see [__] LeBron if he had a
[__] broken mustache follicle he
wouldn't but be but like he gets this
certain people just get like uh it's
just sort of like the default yeah you
know insert this person here I don't
understand the LeBron hate I I
definitely didn't like when he went to
Miami but it's like that guy has been
guaranteed to play a hundred games every
season his entire career his entire
40-year career he's played a hundred
games nothing less that's just a lot
that's a lot it is a lot I think uh
what do you think he's got left four
seasons I don't see him leaving anytime
soon I don't see him he just needs to
find a team to be a role player on but
it's gonna be I don't know what kind of
role player he would be because you know
do you see him being a spot like a spot
up shooter
well this I would just say that this
season of the NBA gave me hope that
maybe you know other teams around rather
than five teams are going to have a shot
and you have to like you know just load
it up with free agents I [__] hate
that [__] right that Ocean's Eleven [__]
it should be it's not it's not like no
it's not competition I think you're
right I think that the NBA has already
gone the way of the NFL where there's
like way more parody parody is the [__]
absolutely because and it's this is what
happened and this is why I say people
who who said that once Rogers left the
Packers were going to be dog [__] like
they were in the 80s it's a different
League than it was in the 80s it's worth
so much money that every roster spot is
so valuable that the talent Rises to the
top there's systems in place as far back
as Middle School these guys know how to
run offenses in high school they get to
College their studs you know they're
already you know they know what they're
doing by the time they get there every
team is going to be good loaded with
Talent coaches know what they're doing
they all came out of a system blah blah
blah and that's great for fans like you
know what for the NBA it's going to be I
hate that the MLB is not like that
because there's no reason why Tampa Bay
shouldn't won a World Series yet if
there was actual parity in that there's
there's such a great [__]
organization
nobody goes to the games they always do
they're killing it again this year
killing it again luxury tax it's because
it's because teams can spend hundreds of
millions of dollars more than others
Steinbrenner rule yes right and when
they buy you all with guys and then then
that becomes the game and then we did it
the Red Sox ended up and then people go
well you guys do it's like well we have
to we have to yeah yeah we have to
because you guys are doing it as a as a
Brewer Fan which they finally started
spending more money and that's awesome
but for a lot of years I was just like
why do I give a [__] about baseball if
that's what it's about if it's about
where the player can make more money in
the off season and who's got the you
know bigger fan base that lives
literally a fun year proximity to the
season fun year was 83 when the Brewers
made a run with Robin and oh yeah
Raleigh fingers Cecil Cooper was Riley
on that team Norman Gorman stormin yeah
dude storm and Gorman yeah and then uh
you went up against Lamar Hoyt in the uh
the White Sox with those crazy uniforms
you guys beat him in Old Comiskey and
you guys were in uh what was what was
the name of that County State County
Stadium yeah I never went to Kaminsky I
did go to a game of County Stadium one
of one of the [__] first few games of
the year so it was like going to a
Packers game it was freezing I sat Upper
Deck behind home plate and just sat
there ooh I I remember I had a uh where
were you working I was doing College
gigs I was working with uh bash Schuler
and they were just like beasts
of the [__] Midwest 40 nights of 40
nights a month oh yeah so they would
always like you know I got a gig in
Rhinelander Wisconsin I can build around
it okay Bill okay they have Bill I got
you in February all set and every 90 to
Winnipeg in every town in between
no there would be some drives though
there was definitely some drives but
like I saw like
the amount of this country that I saw
um doing those College gigs was was
amazing I mean it sucks sometimes with
you know
if they didn't have a mic and you know
the dumb [__] that happens on a lot of
those gigs but like uh the amount of
stuff
that I saw I saw I feel like so much of
the Farmland I mean just like yeah I
remember once that's driving up to
Duluth in like February I was just like
this just takes a special kind of person
to be up I mean like I mean you just got
to be like an ice fisherman yeah you
gotta but you gotta be like watching
your mindset because it'd be so easy to
be like what if I cut a hole in this ice
and just stepped in not just [__]
ended this [__] what if I cut a hole in
my wife that's what I thought you were
gonna say oh no that's Wisconsin yeah
you guys are like where Western
Pennsylvania
you know kept producing quarterbacks the
the sheer amount of serial killers that
have come out of there it's the alcohol
dude it's the weather in the dairy it's
that's a good question I don't know the
dairy could be involved but I think if
anything the dairies kind of saving us
from a maybe a few more serial killers
per capita to be honest with you Ed Gein
ah just get yourself some custard ad
Ted get out of milk he's got that look
in his eye again do you know Ed game was
such a [__] lunatic there's like four
major like Hollywood horror movies that
were all [__] that just he did they they
just couldn't put it all in one movie
Hannibal Lecter Texas Chainsaw murders
both based off of [__] that he did and
uh I'm probably gonna be wrong with it
there was like three or four movies you
sure can we give John Wayne Gacy credit
for any of these where was he Chicago
Chicago
he's the clown he's the fat man in the
clown suit John Wayne Gacy young men in
his basement
we gotta give them some credit we always
focus on Wisconsin they always they
always [__] I see what you're doing
you're trying to turn a ball into a
strike you trying to frame the strike
zone here well I'm not done with
Wisconsin yet then you got Jeffrey
Dahmer
he got a that's another thing I gotta
understand like why somebody would like
uh like watch
like a series on it like that they find
somebody that [__] up fascinating
you know I gotta I watched it it was
pretty interesting to me they did a good
job the first one the hottest people
said he was pretty hot bill it was it
was the first couple would you say as
far as Canimals go is he the Brad Pitt
of cannibals he has to be
he in real life
I feel like John Wayne Gacy was the
dentist Serena no no no no no no no it's
uh it's it's what's his name the boy
next door uh the [__] animal from
Washington who didn't the guy who got on
it Bundy Ted Bundy escaped from prison
twice got on a plane the second time
dude Breckenridge Colorado is
responsible the city of Breckenridge
they let him Escape twice he escaped
from the [__] Courthouse he got on a
plane moved to Florida they were like
nobody said [__] to anybody this is
before the internet they didn't they
wanted to cover their ass they were like
we can't we what do you mean he escaped
again they didn't want to tell anybody
they didn't say [__] to anybody nobody
put the [__] in it nobody put the
connected the dots he killed another 20
women down in Florida that's all
Colorado's fault that's the sorority
right he went down to Colorado and just
went had a [__] went got that's why the
Rockies left and became the Devils I
always wondered that
it always comes back to sports always
about sports
was hot and uh dateable
I'm dude I'm going to a bunch of old
clubs that you that you used to play I'm
doing all your old stuff where you going
well you never played the Lincoln Lodge
in Chicago first and second it's newer
they well you might have done a Lincoln
logic Zanies no no it's it's the uh it
was it was the Indie club and then they
what was that what was that that
Trifecta dates they book you Zanies down
these Rosemonts Lake Charles St Charles
St Charles well no there was also Lake
Vernon or Mount Vernon Mount Vernon St
Charles
and and then and then downtown and then
they recently Mount Vernon closed and
then they would do the uh the Rosemont
Club opened up but those that was a
classic yeah classic run but my thing
was I just like
being such like a sports fan and
everything I loved
you know zany's downtown like I would
still like if I was in Chicago and had
time off yeah and they had to show up
100 would pop in if I could get rid of
these hiccups I would 100 pop in
hilarities Cleveland you love that room
love that room and I remember when that
[__] thing was going when he first
did that he was the only show in town
too everything was like Bleak and dark
because that looked like Escape from New
York and I remember sitting outside of
his Club
you know and you could just feel it like
and I was seeing what was happening in
all these Rust Belt towns I was like and
I remember saying the comic on dude if I
had [__] money I would buy that
building right across the street right
and now I go to now they did it dude it
looks like the [__] Bullwinkle show
is that the nicest Club in America
hilarities uh it's up there yeah it's
just it might be it's like you know what
do you like better pack Bell or where
the Pirates play yeah you know what I
mean it's a Well Done comedy club like
that there's a couple of them yeah
there's always going to be I would say
uh Rogan's Mothership hilarities I
haven't been there I'll be at the creek
in the cave August
next month August yeah hilarities
in Austin
Comedy Works Acme in Minneapolis
I just played Acme it's incredible I
auditioned there one time and he was
like really shut up yeah wow I mean
Lewis is old school dude he's been
around he is that doesn't set the story
you know maybe I sucked that story
I should give it another shot I
auditioned in the early 2000s and I
wasn't good enough but I mean there was
like but it was like Dana Gould Maron
him it was like [__] beasts were
working there yeah and I was just you
know I didn't work there for you ever I
didn't work there I never worked out I
did I auditioned in front of him and he
was just like no
it was funny years later then I saw
somebody bitching about how they sent
him a tape and and you know he didn't
let him in and well and all this
[__] it's like dude I [__]
auditioned in front of the guy didn't
let me in okay yeah you know it's not
always the other person sometimes you're
just not good enough or they don't have
a slot for you they don't get a slap for
you this is just typical gatekeeping or
a level of quality your level of quality
the Market's flooded you started in
impossible career path yeah flooded
Market with Incredible Talent everywhere
A lot of people that [__] you know
close the door said thanks but no thanks
um I just I always in my head I was like
I'm gonna get in there I'll get in there
you know all right not that one whatever
it's in that bat I struck out right it's
looking struck out looking buckled
looking at the cross oh my God yeah
amount of times everybody took a seat
that night yeah it was Nolan Ryan the
amount of times I people
everything from uh
comedy connection Nick's comedy stuff
where I started the comic strip all the
New York clubs
[__] it every single one of them it's
always a no the punch line the punch
line in San Francisco that's incredible
September 20th I'm at the punchline and
you're dropping in my dates in here I
[__] I I drove up there to do a spot
to get on in front of Jeff Wills to try
to get booked there and that was another
one he's just like
you're not ready did you ever do any or
what and I wasn't I wasn't I wasn't
ready yeah I got that I drove across
country with VHS tapes I dropped a VHS
tape off at Cobbs and the punch line
after I graduated college before racist
the summer
the summer before I moved to Chicago I
dropped off VH I drove across country
dropped off a VH VHS tape off to
actually Wills didn't say no he ended up
not showing up and I had driven all the
way up from L.A damn it happens yeah
that happens too but now you know with
social media be like if that was it back
in this Dad or the other he wasn't even
have to [__] audition like they just
it's fantasy this fantasy it's like oh
you think and you think we're all us
dudes are out here all helping each
other I mean you're this is a maybe not
the you're helping me but like it's like
we're all competition this business is
[__] sharks what the [__] do you
think this Stitch you tried to do you
think you just get handed
being yourself for a living but you have
to drive eight hours to do five minutes
for free and then get right back in your
car and drive back eight hours
or you don't do this or you don't do it
and you have to do that over and over
and over again at least back then you
did I like now where
uh these kids today have so much power
and that they can like put Clips out and
everything and they can kind of uh
they they can they have the power to to
make it on their own which I think is
really uh is really cool and it's kind
of fascinating watching the industry
scampering trying to prove that you
still need them
you know what I mean yes it's it's
becoming like well as far as like a
comedian you can really just be this
self-sustained yes unit I mean you don't
need anybody
to write your jokes you're writing those
jokes you don't need anybody to help you
promote them right you'll promote them
if they're good they're going to get out
there and then you don't need anybody to
have you start a [__] podcast just go
buy the [__] and you kind of have it and
then
I feel like you're your own little
business and then if you wanna if you
want somebody
to help blow your [__] up you hire
somebody that knows how to do it so
you're still in control you don't go to
them because they have they just keep
doing the okay you come here and we own
50 of your podcasts
money goes to us and then we'll pay you
and then our names on the check so you
never saw the original check so there's
no way you can steal from us but we can
[__] steal from you you grow your
business it's your business they grow
your business it's that's not your
business it's their business yeah
one of the best things I ever saw was
this stuff the best the best things that
ever happened to me were people saying
no to me
for real because I had to take control
of my career and I had to do [__] on my
own I had to release my own albums I
mean the best you know not getting
back from a suicide attempt right yeah
you appreciate things you see the light
you have your head in the oven you think
what am I doing it's just jokes it gives
you perspective
um anyway the special is called live at
the Green Mill
uh
um I don't know what else to say dude
other than like I I just love your stuff
and uh you can see
you know the way this thing is shot the
level of quality that the stand-up is
gonna be so
um
you know I don't know what else are we
doing are we working together we're
working together this weekend right
working together this week we're doing
Tacoma and Edmonton we're doing The
Great Outdoors Festival we're at this
casino up in Tacoma on Saturday we're
doing The Great Outdoors Festival in
Edmonton on Sunday and then we're
working together in October too we'll be
uh we'll be all over yeah doing a little
bit of bus tour all right one more event
did you ever do the um you're a Michigan
guy did you ever do you ever do the Ann
Arbor comedy showcase
I dropped a tape off to them you did now
Roger a great guy long time ago and I
was I was I mean talking like late 90s
yeah
and uh uh I was doing some college gigs
there oh man yeah and I just I had I
would
that's what I would do I did it at the
comedy The Comedy Works too remember
Adam Ferraro is headlining and I
remember coming in like oh my God Adam
Ferrara yeah is headlining
the Denver comedy wishes he realized how
huge like he just I would just look at
people like that had the gig like wow
and look he's not even nervous like he's
just in and the owner loves and I would
come in you know I hand them I did that
in a lot of places sure a lot of places
I would uh you know the improvs were
really good about shoeing you away like
yeah no no no because everybody but like
those sort of those independent ones
uh yeah
and then you run into somebody's the
personal tastes of a Booker and that's
what you have to it takes so long I mean
I was never good at it still I'm not
good at it but I think you could at
least compartmentalize now when somebody
doesn't like you or they want it they
you know because that's all their taste
you know the booker of a club that they
either own or I did a guest spot at some
place when I was in Utah and I went and
I was psyched and I went up and uh
I had a good set that led to nothing
like Wise Guys or something whatever the
[__] was out there sure uh I did uh a
couple places in Seattle
this is all coming back to me
underground underground yes the
underground I would do I played with
college and then I would rush over to
try to go on late to say I'm a comic
from New York City blah blah blah you
know started in Boston
you know I can't is it you know and they
would just take the tape and remember
they would walk into the thing and they
would just be just these
[__] the warehouse in Indiana Jones
oh yeah yeah it just gave it to a guy
who put it on a forklift all right well
at least it's a forklift necessary yeah
at least I cleared some space in my
apartment
um yeah that was how it was done but now
you can
film yourself they do it's that is that
is a really interest just the way comedy
is now like they do have the but they
it's also there's so many Comics that
have that same power that it's like man
there's there's advantages but there's
such disadvantages now like I don't know
how the the crazy Comics do it the
cream's gonna write if you listen I look
at if you put now killer [__] okay uh
consistently people
are gonna know who you are I [__] you
know I I
repost like five Comics I don't even
know if I just see a funny [__] joke
I love it when you do that I'm putting
that out there I love it when you do
that I try to do that too but I mean I
mean you know you got you got such an
audience that like when you when you put
somebody out there that's so funny
that's just like because not not all
guys at your level do that so uh it's uh
well you know it's a big deal maybe it's
because I grew up in Massachusetts where
we just had the Boston Strangler and we
never tried to turn him into a sex
symbol the way you guys did out there in
Wisconsin I see what you just did there
yeah yeah that's that's that's I didn't
even shoot it across the mile yeah I
threw it you threw it right in my face
that's right I took the plastic you you
threw my own folder my own State's most
[__] serial killer huh right back in
my face no shirts maybe I'm jealous no
shirt sunscreen and everything
but you gotta admit when when you're
watching a sporty and sporting event
from Wisconsin or Massachusetts when
they cut to the crowd
I mean it's nothing but animals right
it's full they're both yeah but there's
specific animals
like you know there's no tigers in
Africa right I didn't realize that
they're not they're like in Asia yeah
okay there's like there's just in East
Coast animal is different
than a than a than a a Midwest animal
like the sports fan [__] animal you
know by the way I'm actually kind of
calling out Philadelphia recently I'm
sick of this stereotypical I've gone to
sporting events they're not all that
[__] crazy I feel like they they feel
like they have to do this performative
yeah yeah it's starting to become I'm
that crazy Philly guy oh boy yeah I
don't I don't ever really I'm not really
I don't that doesn't ever really impress
me I don't I go to Philly and it's not a
bunch of mouth breathing [__] morons
who are absolutely shit-faced big
[__] deal you you outnumber you
outnumber the the the fans from out of
town ten to one you and 80 your dudes
can follow two dudes around and [__]
mean mug them and act like you you know
no I don't mean that [__] I don't mean
that [__] like every stadium is is
Wisconsin was nice Wisconsin's nice and
also so is Soldier I never had a bad
time at Soldier Field I've been a
soldier field 10 times right 90 days
probably I've been down even when the
Bears played in Champaign I went there
once I just when people are wrapped
inside for long enough for a large
enough portion of the year they value
the one afternoon of the month that
they're going outside and they're not
trying to do anything but drink their
[__] faces off now that's Seattle fan
the Seahawks fan are they bad fans or is
that guy bad I just think I just think
that Seahawks fans are the corniest fans
in the league the whole 12-man [__]
that started because they were getting
ripped off
on the beers that's the best that is the
like one of the original viral videos
how did that guy ride that out dude I
don't know how they get well what they
did if people listen and don't know one
of the Seahawks were so bad and the
season ticket holders were all fed up
and then they figured out one of the
season ticket holders took a large beer
poured it into a small beer same beer
same same amount and uh and oh yeah
there was a tall a tall skinny one was a
large and then a short one small
somebody drank the small and then poured
the large in three dollars more there's
another podcast we're going over here
all right let me do my dates real quick
all right do your dates real quick I'm
telling you guys if you go see this guy
you're not going to be disappointed if
you like top-notch comedy I'm so proud
to have my name on your special I'm in
right thank you Bill you're [__]
killing it Creek in the cave Austin
Texas August 18th and 19th I'll be at
the Lincoln Lodge in Chicago September
1st and 2nd I'll be at the punch line
September 20th in San Francisco I'll be
at the Ann Arbor comedy showcase
September 29th and 30th I'll be with
Bill all over the country for a week
I'll be at polarities in November 16th
through the 18th hilarities in Cleveland
I'll be at the Majestic Theater in
Madison Wisconsin December 27th and I'll
be at the Laughing tap in Milwaukee
Wisconsin for New Year's Eve the whole
weekend that's it Nate Craig live at the
Green Mill on youtube.com
ATC I just hit the camera thank you so
much for coming on continued success I'm
a huge fan all right thank you guys
all right
[Music]
what's going on it's Bill Burr and it's
the Monday Morning podcast for Monday
July 13th
2015. what's going on how are ya
I just had a really embarrassing moment
right it's Sunday afternoon
is there a song about Sunday afternoons
rainy days and Mondays oh Jesus Sunday
afternoon because now it goes
oh thank you yeah
um that's a really embarrassing thing I
[__] Andrew
who sends me all the podcast [__]
I'm walking my dog around the block
right
and he tells me to call him so I call
him so he tells me that he's sending me
the podcast [__] so I go to it you know
I come back with the dog
and I go to [__] check my emails and
it's not there in fact I haven't got one
[__] email since July 10th which
never happened so I check my little mini
iPad thing it won't let it's refreshing
it won't give me anything else I check
my [__] iPhone I got the six now
just like all you kids out there playing
the [__] avatar games the one single
person first person uh I'll blow your
[__] face off in the comfort of my uh
attic bedroom all right I got the new
one none of them no emails for two days
so I'm like what the [__] this [__]
happens to me all the time so I lose my
[__]
I call Andrew up and he's going oh
that's weird that's strange I never
heard of that Alice that people always
say about my [__] and then he tells me
he hasn't told he hasn't sent it yet let
me try sending them and then they came
through so there was nothing wrong
it was just my dumb ass had not got an
email in two days and I thought I was so
[__] important that I at least get a
little bit of spam
so yeah so whatever this [__] egg an
old freckles face here you know so I'm
starting off humble
starting off humble like that [__]
Irish guy there with his chest tattoo
running around talking all this [__]
that he was gonna do to the half of the
[__] world
now listen I don't watch a lot of UFC so
I don't even know any of the [__]
names
but I watched that you know and I'm part
Irish and that guy's skipping around
like a [__] leprechaun talking all
that [__] it just [__] annoyed me so
now I'm I'm now I'm rooting for Barney
Rubble
Latino Barney Rubble that Mendes dude
right
and [__] uh what what this face there
who looks like he looks like uh he looks
like a combination of uh the guy from
the Spin Doctors and uh that creepy
mascot for Burger King I can't figure
out what he is except he can [__]
spin around and put his heel on your
temple
all right so I'm watching this [__]
and he's talking all this [__] and he's
doing all that Roy Jones like I'm gonna
humiliate you
while I beat you and uh which of course
is making me root for the little fella
I mean who do I see in there even though
that guy's a pasty [__] with red hair
just like me he's actually got a full
head of hair the son of a [__] right
um
I want a root form
you know what I mean
little [__] redhead solidarity I want
a roof for this guy but he's such a [__]
in the first halfway through the first
round I'm like you know what [__] this
guy
let's go shooting
right I'm rooting for the little guy the
little guys [__] starts taking him to
the mat
he's [__] throwing elbows
this [__] little [__] Burger King
guy is eating these things and then he
gets up and he kind of nods like oh yeah
that was pretty good that was pretty
good pretty good you got to cut over
your eye they have freckles right next
thing you know next round comes out the
[__] little guy is putting this
freckled [__] on his back
ground and pound ground and pound ground
and pound okay and [__] uh Ireland's
Burger King guy gets back up
he gets back up and all of a sudden he's
not talking [__] anymore he's got a
little [__] yeah that was pretty good
that was pretty good
pretty good he was on top of you the
whole [__] round long story [__]
short I think it was the third round he
[__] does it again
he's just on top of this guy beating his
[__] ass
all right he gets up
you know which is good on the [__]
redheaded dude he [__] gets up
Connor whatever McLaughlin or is it
Sarah McLaughlin I don't know what the
[__] his name is Connor something or
other right he [__] gets up
and uh the the little guys gassed the
guy got two weeks notice this other
[__] been training for months to fight
this Jose Josie whatever the [__] his
name is right so the little fellas
gassed he catches a [__] left he goes
down he's covered up he's not fighting
back but he's covering up and
immediately the [__] dude steps in I
said knock it off that'll be it
and then the Spin Doctors guy jumps up
and down you know and jumps on the
[__] cage
you know it starts crying into the iron
Ireland flag
okay now I'm not saying that that
[__] Irish dude's not a badass
fighter I'm not saying that I'm just
saying that little fella he earned the
right
he earned the right to ride out that
round get to the chair and then you look
at him you want to go out again granted
he was gassed maybe they saved him but
you know I don't know I don't know [__]
about the sport I don't even know the
[__] names but all I can tell you was
that evidently that was going to be a
big fight you know when mayor McGee's
there was going to fight Josie in the
[__] whatever [__] name is right
that's that that's why the fight game
man I'm telling you right now anybody
who who who is the Don King of the sport
you should [__] you should have to
dress like Boss Hog because to me that
[__] reeked of a quick stoppage
you can't tell me this is of course you
can tell me
the [__] do I know I'm just a comedian
right
and I play one on TV too right
that just reeked of holy [__] we thought
he was gonna beat this little bastard's
ass and we're gonna get a two for one on
the pay-per-view here because everybody
you know the Irish guy talks so much
[__] you're gonna watch him anyways
right
I know I sound like a [__] [__] you it
seemed like [__] to me it just
seemed like [__]
or maybe I've watched Rocky too many
times I wanted that little fella to [__]
the whole thing up I wanted him to [__]
up the big payday and it didn't happen
Okay hats off to the Irish guy all right
double hats off because he's also
redhead you know he's making us look
good God knows we take a bunch of [__]
I just thought it was a quick stoppage
and good on him that he took that
pounding and was able to get back up
again but I'll tell you right now
that was not a good fight for that guy
I would guess because I would think that
the other guy would be like oh that's
very interesting very interesting what
that little fella there did on only
[__] two weeks training is it amazing
how much [__] I'm giving to people who
in their sleep like walking in their
sleep could [__] choke me up
the second I brushed up against them
with any sort of energy that they didn't
like you know is this still muttering in
their sleep about [__] a bowl of corn
flakes they'd still choke me out doesn't
stop me from talking [__]
like the [__] that I am in my own
podcast and the safety
of my own of my own uh office
within my house oh yeah I'll [__]
talk [__] about anybody in here
you get me outside the confines of my
gate hey how are you nice to see you I I
like your shirt
um anyways it was it was a great what a
[__] if you didn't rent it man I I
would rent that [__] UFC 189 for as much
as I'm being a little [__] rag and
[__] here just wired a wire every fight
was a [__] knockout
was unbelievable you know my favorite
part of the night was when Rogan was
watching whatever fight it was
where uh
I don't [__] know this white dude was
fighting this other guy and the guy's
just swinging wildly and and uh
Rogan actually laughed at one point you
know not like you know no disrespect to
the fighter he just was enjoying the
fight and he sort of laughed and said
this is a bar fight and uh
this [__] maniac
you know a lot of Fighters you know
after they win the fight when they're
celebrating they look scary but the
second they start talking this to
totally chill there's a few of them that
can't shut it off and you're like
that guy you know like that big dude and
uh The Dirty Dozen Posey
remember that come on Posey stick them
stick them yeah yeah I'm pushing you and
he's the [__] Lee Marvin's pushing
him then he just [__] snaps and he's
just like stop pushing and he can't
[__] shut it off
and he wants to drive [__] Lee
Marvin's nose right through his brain
and keep punching until he [__] goes
his fist and his forearm goes right
through the brains of his entire [__]
family tree like that guy had like that
energy
there was so many sick I really should
know these Fighters names especially
considering I'm trying to get in shape
and these guys are in some of the best
shape he could possibly be and
um I don't know I'm not gonna pretend
like I know anything about the sport all
I can tell you was I 100 got my [__]
money's worth
and uh other than I just thought they
stopped the fight a little too soon but
really thinking about it
I think I was just being selfish because
I wanted that little dude to upset him I
gotta stop calling little dude the guy
was shorter than the [__] redhead
um he [__]
I just I thought he earned the right to
get to the [__] corner and be like
dude can you go are you gassed or
whatever
but then of course he's gonna say yeah I
can go and then maybe he would actually
really get [__] up you know
you know Bill maybe if you think about
it maybe the official referee
um
of that Pay-Per-View fight maybe knows a
little bit more maybe it was a little
bit closer maybe has watched a few more
fights than you did and maybe he stopped
it at the right time
ah right whatever I I wanted to see it
keep going I want to see him put him on
his back again
damn it
I love when that happens I love when an
underdog [__] it like some dude comes
in he's not supposed to fight this guy
or it's just supposed to be this tune-up
fight
for the big [__] payday and this guy
comes in and just [__] knocks him out
knocks the dude out I always imagined
like that would be that that's what it
would be like if you somehow interrupted
like the New World Order you know and
I'm not saying that this shape shifters
but I'm saying if you if you honestly
think that these [__] maniacs
that there's not a group of people that
want to run it all and Own It All
then I I don't know I don't know then I
wish I was you I wish I lived where you
lived and saw what you saw that you
haven't seen that [__] human behavior
but uh
I don't know I'm out of my phone go [__]
yourself it's a Sunday afternoon I'm
hanging out by myself my wife's not
around I've been talking to my dog all
day did you do you think that this is
going to make sense
well do you
um well did you I should have yelled um
anyways but uh
in the next UFC I go in and out of the
UFC you know what I mean like I do with
like wrestling when they don't have a
lot of good stars or whatever I start to
fade or whatever I get busy in my
[__] life I should watch it because
whenever I watch it it motivates me
to get in shape you know what I mean or
if I even watch Like The Ultimate
Fighter which I know that's kind of like
Making the Band
uh or Who Wants To Be A Millionaire for
like [__] Fighters you know I mean I
don't know how many guys actually came
out of uh
that [__] house that went on to do
some [__] you know I think most of them
are like you know those people that sing
during the first week of American Idol
you know those people Jimmy crack corn
and I don't care all right buddy you're
not going to Vegas
and they cried at the camera at least I
did it you know I came here I threw some
uppercuts and
yeah I got knocked out but whatever man
I had the balls to come here you know
what I mean most of them end up like
that and and as always even that crying
little [__] douchebag could kick the
[__] out of me in his sleep I admit all
of that before any of you [__] come at
me like maybe you want to talk [__]
about something you can actually be in a
fight maybe you should go [__] yourself
he says in the safety of his own office
within his house behind his gate
um
so anyways the next UFC which I I'm
gonna go out on a limb and say is going
to be UFC uh 190.
um the constipation or whatever they're
kind of out of adjectives I think they
finally stopped doing that
remember that
the Revenge Factor
and it was like uh deportation
um canceled reservation UFC 143 they
just ran out so they just have they just
call them by numbers now so I think 190.
is going to be that's that's going to be
down in Brazil the beginning of August
and what's great
is uh Rowdy Rondo Rousey
uh I hope I said is it Rhonda Rondo
Rousey
how do I not remember names
once again someone else who kicked the
[__] out of me in her sleep
um
she's fighting she's fighting in Brazil
and she's fighting the top woman in
Brazil
uh and what's great about that is
I just that's it's going to be so great
to watch her shut an entire nation down
you know I think the biggest problem
she's going to have is security trying
to get the [__] out of there after she
beats that woman's ass because I think
she's gonna and you know why because I
watched about 0.8 seconds of highlights
on on her opponent
you know what I mean
oh I'm talking about the fight game I am
in whale of my head [__] you it's the
dog days of summer hockey's over
basketball is over there's no football
what do you want from me
the [__] do you want from me so I don't
know anything can happen is what I've
learned
watching fights or whatever and I know
that Brazilian girl she's got one of
those Brazilian booties so who knows if
she gets low she gets low who knows what
can happen you know what I mean she puts
that thing to [__] work
who knows um but I don't think it's
gonna happen
um
anyways
yeah the dog days are summer so
I watched uh I missed the men's final
was today as I said I'm taping here on
uh Sunday
um
congratulations to uh Djokovic you know
coming back after you losing the French
Open
he beat Andy Federer I would have liked
to have seen that maybe they'll replay
it on the tennis channel actually
watched the replay of Serena winning the
Serena slam
you know she won last year's U.S open
then she won the Australian then she won
the French and now she won Wimbledon so
she won the last four in a row and who's
kid no she'll win the [__] U.S open
uh and the record is six I Believe by
Martina travelola
um I think
and I'm by going I glanced at Wikipedia
for two seconds I have no idea but uh
I'm rooting for she needs one more to
tie Steffi Graf
and obviously one more after that she'll
have won the most ever which is pretty
amazing that not only she can do that
but she can do it at her age
um gee bill that was very informative it
wasn't funny on any [__] level all
right relax okay so
as I mentioned last week
freckles
oh freckles is on the wagon show me the
way to go home boom boom I'm tired and I
wanna go to bed
um
I've been on the wagon now for seven
days
no boost and um I was a like a buck 80s
186.6 my way and I wanted to lose three
pounds a week
for the next like two months to get
myself down to my fighting weight and I
got on the scale
this afternoon and I was 183.2 so I
actually lost 3.4 pounds
so next week you know I need to be down
to 180. so if you want to do it with me
this is what I'm doing this is my diet
this is what's this what's works for me
and what I'm doing I wake up in the
morning I take my dog
I take my dog
for like an hour-long hike
and uh I come back
and then I um
I have oatmeal and a banana
and then between lunch
and uh and breakfast I either have an
apple or an orange
and so I get two helpings of fruit
before 12. after 12 if I'm gonna have
I'll only have a vegetable I won't have
a fruit just because it's got all the
sugar
so then for lunch as you can tell this
is not an exciting diet and as you can
tell by the incredible lack of passion
in my voice but it's working for me
you know as Whitney and Bobby Brown used
to say it works it works for me it works
sorry I have a black wife so I see stuff
like that on TV
I have a black wife my wife is black
African-American sir
um so anyways
um
anybody remember that episode Whitney
and Bobby Brown It's kind of tragic now
obviously uh really you think so Bill
said daughter's in a coma
um when they were [__] in the store
and they were trying on hats or
something sunglasses and they're both
probably high
and they go does it work it works then
they just started doing this song it
works it works for me it works doing
this [__] dance and everyone's
staring at him
um it was actually a nice moment
anyways uh
what was I talking about oh yeah so
and then in the afternoon
um
what do I usually have in the afternoon
that's kind of whatever I don't know
that's that's a little weird
the afternoon one
what the [__] do I usually have I try to
have something healthy that's usually
I'll have like a bowl of cereal just
something
to throw a little flare into the day but
then at night I go uh I eat super
healthy right around between five and
six you know protein the size of the
Palm you had and then just a bunch of
vegetables and then I just Crush [__]
waters for the rest of the night
um and I'm not drinking anything else
but water to be honest with you and uh
and then if I do get hungry at night and
I need a late night snack I have a bunch
of celery sticks already cut up and I'll
take like a [__] like a spoonful of
peanut butter I know I know but you know
what it works
it works [__] [__] all I gotta do
is just live like this for three [__]
months and I can get down to my fighting
weight not three months two months and
uh yeah do it with me
eight times three it's twenty of you'll
lose 24 pounds with me all right do it
with me
get your Beachbody like me in September
[Laughter]
so anyways you don't even have to do
this [__] I'm just telling you guys that
I'm gonna do it so I stay off the I stay
on the wagon Freudian slip there
stay on the wagon and then I also
continue to drop my three pounds a week
um
whatever man you know what I mean next
week will be six pounds and in between
week two and three that's when people
start noticing which motivates you even
more so uh
no Jesus and and then I just been doing
like the push-ups and the pull-ups and
that type of thing
um Bert Kreischer sent me this thing on
Twitter
about how to improve your grip strength
this Men's Health thing in the first
exercise I've actually been able I got
myself worked up I can do is basically
you hang from a chin up bar
uh three sets of one minute
um but you wouldn't think it's hard but
it is
it can be or whatever if you're a fat
[__] like I am oh God I hate myself
right now
um so that's what I'm doing I'm eating
right and I'm watching the UFC's I'm
watching boxing I'm just looking at
people in shape
you know what I mean
if you're a fat [__] watch men that are
in shape with your wife
and you'll feel it on her like God I
wish my husband looked like that and I'm
telling you it'll motivate you to get
down there and get on the [__] mat
um so anyways Hey listen I got an idea
here why don't I promote this right now
so you know I sell these posters on the
road and uh I come home and I'll I'll
have some extra ones and I autograph
them I send them out we ship them out
people buy them and we ship them out so
the last time
um
we had the ones from the uh the southern
tour
and uh you know we ship those out
everybody got their [__] orders
you know no problem but it did take
longer a lot of people were like where
the [__] is it because it took us a long
time to get them out because we do
everything ourselves here so know this
all the posters we have that are left
over from my uh my week in Boston where
I did the 19 shows
um
those are all autographed and they're
already packaged in the tube ready to go
all we need is for you to order them and
um we'll just slap a label on them and
uh my guy is telling me that these
[__] will be out
by uh by Tuesday so they will go on sale
um
tonight at 10 p.m Pacific time which is
[__] stupid I'm gonna I gotta tweet
about it
um
they're all autographed and whatnot and
uh
what else all right well so if you don't
want to if you wanna um send an email to
the podcast it's Bill at
themmpodcast.com that's where you send
it and um
whatever so if you'd like an autograph
posted poster from my historic run
or stupid run depending on who you are
of 19 shows in Boston uh we had some
leftover ones we had about about three
four hundred of them I got them all
autographed they make a great gift for
someone that you like or maybe don't
give a [__] about the 20 bucks plus the
shipping you can order them right off my
website billboard.com just click on the
merch page and uh like I said we already
got them all boxed up or tubed up
whatever you're supposed to say and
they're ready to go so if you want one
uh I would appreciate it buying it if
not I get it I get it
um so anyways
anyways what else did I want to talk
about I'm going through here oh thank
you to everybody that sent me in all the
information about the Ford Galaxies I
should have mentioned that I wanted a
two-door and I believe I said 65 or 66.
a lot of people sent me [__] from 63 64
68. that was still cool 67 because I got
to learn how the car has changed but um
um two of them were really what I wanted
and I called both and they were already
gone so
um I think once a month I'll put the
word out to you guys and I'll keep
looking for it but uh
you know I don't know
didn't work out this week what are you
gonna do I already got my truck my
truck's going my it's not starting well
I figured out what the antifreeze thing
was I had it parked on this really Steep
Hill
and just because it's [__] old it
doesn't have any stop
I don't know something to block the [__]
antifreeze just started dribbling out
overnight so it wasn't even that much
but uh there's been no antifreeze not
anything that's dripped out since then
and if you saw the amount that was there
in the morning you would think I had a
major problem
um and nothing has happened ever since
then and yes thank you to everybody out
there who told me to check the radiator
to make sure you had enough antifreeze I
did do that but I appreciate you letting
me know anyways
and uh so everything's all good with
that and I [__] love driving that
truck so so there you go so
so here we go
um
let's see what am I going to talk about
here Jesus the whole [__] podcast
just fellow pass why you don't do those
announcements in the middle of it it
kills my whole my whole uh [__]
whatever oh I didn't mention you don't
want to eat dinner I basically
I don't know I eat steak or eat chicken
I try to stay away from fish unless it's
like salmon and I only eat salmon
because we can we grow it ourselves in a
[__] petri dish and even though it
might cause cancer someday I don't think
I'm more important than all the fish in
the [__] ocean so I'm Gonna Roll the
Dice that that genetically altered
[__] up salmon that I'm eating is not
as bad as it probably is but um you know
I was watching Shark Week this week on
the Discovery Channel and those guys I
got to give it up to the Discovery
Channel they've come a long way on way
they on the way that they depict sharks
but they still always have like that
Jaws [__] vibe to it and I really
it's [__] reprehensible that they do
it but at the end of the day you know
what they're not scientists they're a
[__] Network and they don't give a
[__] about nature you know what I mean
they always got to do that [__] like
like the shark has some personal
Vendetta
like in all those Jaws movies like after
like after they fought off the shark
they'd start driving away you know in
the boat or whatever you do sailing away
there's no sale I guess you drive away
right whatever the [__] they're doing
and then the shark follows them
like the shark's like oh these you
[__] think this [__] is over
this [__] ain't over
right like it wants to kill these
[__] people
um
but then again it's just a movie you
would think that the Discovery Channel
wouldn't have that they had this [__]
one right
you know and I always watch the first
three quarters because once they start
going to the end they start showing what
we're doing and how many sharks were
killing and how bad we're [__] up the
ocean like I saw something on the
Discovery Channel where this scientist
was going at this fish market
in uh somewhere in like Southeast Asia
and he just because once you just
mentally get past all the amount sheer
amount of of dead fish there
that are being consumed every [__]
day what he he's looking what he's
looking at is
the different species and what he's
finding is he's seeing species of fish
that you never saw in a fish market
anymore and that's because they used to
drag the Nets you know up at the surface
and now because that's basically been
fished out we are now
likes I don't know how many feet down
it was some
level of
whatever the [__] it was how many 600
feet 500 feet I don't know what the [__]
we were but it it
sent chills down my spine like what the
[__] are we doing and why isn't anybody
talking about it in political office
right so they were dragging up species
of fish that you just never see the fish
market just for the simple fact they
never dragged the Nets down that low and
uh there's a couple of [__] up looking
sharks and like you know those fish that
you know you start getting so [__]
low you know they're having eyes isn't
that important
finding some really [__] up looking
stuff like you like is that from this
planet I've never seen one of those
before so I'm trying to lay off Sushi
and I'm trying to lay off all that stuff
so I've I've dropped that down and a lot
of my friends are telling me that they
eat bison and that type of [__] anything
that we
I'm gonna just try to eat [__] that we
um
like pigs cows chickens even though I
know they're not [__] healthy but I
mean at least we're reproducing that
[__] and considering we're the ones that
are [__] it up anyways shouldn't I be
the one that eats it
you know shouldn't I die rather than a
bunch of [__] fish
I don't know I'm watching that [__] and
going on that that bus tour I took
through California right [__]
hilarious me and Joe bartner got a giant
bus just tearing up the [__]
atmosphere
such a hypocrite you know but I'm
cutting down on the fish dude
um
just seeing how low the water is out
here it's uh it's a [__] you know
it's getting there dude it's slow not
even slowly it's [__] getting crazy
out there so
um
I don't know the one exciting thing I
heard about the weather out here is they
might have an El Nino so it would
actually give us some rain not nearly
enough as we need but at least some
[__] rain
so uh I'm really hoping for that I'm
hoping that's going to happen for the
next four [__] years in a row because
uh I don't know going over the uh the
Hoover and seeing how low the [__]
water was was pretty scary why do you
need to hear about this you don't need
to [__] hear about it right
all right bombing you out the beginning
of gee Bill really is the [__] world
going to hell in a hand basket we get it
um
so anyways I watched a little bit of the
Yankees Red Sox today because I missed
the men's final and it was [__]
nothing else on
and um
I got to be honest dude you know I don't
think other than Pedroia Ortiz and
Xander Bogarts I don't know anybody on
our [__] team
um except that guy from The Outfield
Shane Victorino I guess I know four guys
you know I didn't know any Yankees and
it was really weird to see it looked
like Alfonso Soriano with short
um I don't know they kind of look like
the Yankees look like the the like the
Dave Righetti Yankees to me and
um I don't know the Red Sox look like
the [__] 88 Red Sox to me it's really
sort of a weird time but I watched a
couple of innings
you know we were down two nothing we
went up three to two
I made an effort
I made an effort um so next week I fly
up to the Montreal Comedy Festival I'm
doing a Blues Festival in Ottawa
if you want to get tickets just go to
billboard.com and then uh I'm doing two
shows in Montreal
sock wearing Frenchies
yeah I'm going up there I'm gonna have a
good [__] time
um and as they trash my Bruins for not
making the playoffs all I gotta say is
and how did you guys do
no we made the playoffs oh did you did
you win the cup yeah that's what I
thought
um
22 years and and Counting
of the [__] this is the longest
drought in Montreal Canadian history and
I am enjoying every [__] day of it
every [__] day of it
um
and you know who's getting to know the
Bruins I don't know what we're gonna do
next year
I have no [__] idea how you replace
lucich what do you do you sign some
[__] goon from Philly that that's
supposed to fill the void
um
I don't know I'm still [__]
shell-shocked what the Bruins did we
[__] do that [__] every every [__]
time somebody well you know they wanted
90-year contract in a bunch of money at
some point you gotta pay somebody
you gotta get how the [__] do you get
rid of lucich everybody had a bad year
he underfucking produced
maybe you guys didn't put the right team
on the [__] ice what's he supposedly
supposed to do all of it all right all
right all right what am I doing I'm
yelling at my own [__] team here
anyways
um
so yes I'm doing two shows up in
Montreal
um Wednesday and Thursday of next week
so that would be 15 and the 22nd and the
23rd I'm doing shows at a theater up
there I think if they're not sold out
they're close to being sold out but if
you'd like to watch me play drums when
I'm up there
Monday Tuesday and Thursday the seven
o'clock show the goddamn Comedy Jam
I am going to be up there
um playing a song each night having a
great time telling stories about uh my
failed drumming career and all the all
the awful [__] I wasn't even ever
even in a band I never even got my drums
out of my basement my people used to
just come over and we would play and uh
you know I was always the worst [__]
guy so I get plenty of funny stories to
tell about that [__] so
um
anyways let's let's get to some of the
[__] questions here for the oh you
know what I haven't done the [__]
advertising for this week
oh Jesus oh Jesus where are we
come on Bell for [__] sakes can you
for once in your life learn how to come
ah Jesus Christ thank God that's done
take Christ that's done so
um anyways I want to thank everybody for
just sending in all these uh oh wait a
minute these four galaxies
I got a couple here
America's dream cars oh [__]
dude that's the one right there
holy [__] that's still one 65-4 Galaxy
500 two-door runs very well that means
it's a piece of [__]
289 V8 motor motor 47 000 miles liar
Automatic Transition white with IV
interior
looks like it's blue to me
All Chrome
is with the car
oh Jesus this is getting bad original
chrome rust free frame interior is
original and needs to be restored this
is a North Carolina car it is solid
everywhere if you're looking for a good
driving classic
price 2500 bucks Jesus Christ can you go
wrong
oh my God that might be the one
thank you forever whoever sent me that
one
I'm all right Garden
oh something got cut off here it says
Thursday podcast Bill I'm obsessed with
and then it just says T I don't know
what you're obsessed with All Right
Guard Billy Green Thumb I think someone
used this before I don't think they did
I was listening to old podcasts you were
talking about making your your makeshift
Garden out there in Los Los Angeles can
we have an update yeah the update is we
are in a Biblical level drought and um
you know I'm not allowed to water my
grass and that type of [__] so uh
you know I just water what I have I got
a couple of tomato plants I got a lemon
and lime tree can you believe I got a
lime tree and not an avocado tree what a
[__] jerk off
so
um
I gotta make sure I uh I handle that oh
great why is it reloading what is going
on here
um
I'm all for that though growing your own
food and that type of stuff and uh you
know during this time I'm not joking man
I'm really gonna try to eat a lot less
fish than as much as I joke about it
that is a serious [__] problem and uh
I'm gonna try to I'm actually gonna try
to learn to make a couple of vegan meals
that actually taste good because I'm
always going to eat steak and that type
of [__] but I'm just gonna try to
incorporate a couple of those things
because uh it keeps you in shape man it
does and it helps you lose [__]
weight
so anyways
um so that is the update uh I wish I had
a whole garden but I don't
and I'm hoping eventually I can I'm just
hoping the water comes back here someday
and if it doesn't I am going to take a
bath on this house
all righty music hey Bill my wife has
great taste in music except for stuff
that really sucks
he kind of went two ways there
um of Nia's music what group or band or
genre do you absolutely have do you have
absolutely no ability to swallow
um my wife has unbelievable taste in
music uh uh particularly [__] that I
wouldn't be exposed to
especially at my age 47 year old white
guy I'm not going to know what the
latest
you know even just hits are in the whole
rap World
um and you guys owe me a big a big pat
on the back there because I didn't use
the Expression hip-hop I didn't want you
guys to hear that coming out of my
[__] mouth
um so
I stay up you know she she's always
listen to some [__] you know
I like to make money get turnt that [__]
got the white girls Marco Polo or
twerking Polo work that guy
um
shoot that [__] she listens to that
Wyclef Rocky whatever the [__] his name
is hashtag Rocky
money bags dollar sign Rocky I can't
remember what his [__] name is she
listens to uh Lil Wayne
uh
Kanye who I can't I can't stand I listen
to that guy he just tells me about how
awesome he is and all the stuff he has
it's excruciatingly boring
um
but he isn't he's not bored with himself
at all he is absolutely amazed with how
amazing he is with and God knows that's
fun to listen to
[Laughter]
[Applause]
tell me tell me in another verse why
you're so awesome
um anyways
you know something I'll tell you right
now the stuff that it's not her music
she has great great taste in music and I
mean like she's one of those people that
you can just grab her [__] iPhone and
put it on shuffle and just put it on at
a party and nothing embarrassing comes
on everybody's like [__] what song is
that what song is that like she's
really uh up on all the good [__]
music but um
so anyways uh the thing that bothers me
is the [__] that she watches on TV oh
Jesus Christ does she watch some dumb
[__] man
you know and a lot of smart women watch
that reality [__] evidently they like it
and even though they're smart it's like
you know I guess it's it's like me
watching sports hang on one second the
company's here I gotta close the door
hold on hold on hang on hang on
hang on hang on
so anyway she watches all those uh
those [__] real housewives shows
but what she did recently
and this was devastating
what does that sound I thought she was
talking to my wife yelling me she put
the TV on this is my my wife bought
Kim Kardashian
I'm just [__] on this whole couple
you know God bless him he sells at the
Staple Center and she goes shopping
whatever the [__] she does right God
bless both of them continued success
um
she she Kim Kardashian put out this book
okay
and all the whole book is nothing but
her selfies
she put out a book of selfies of herself
not like a bunch of people taking
selfies that would have been bad enough
but it was it's all pictures of her
and
the cover of it is her just standing
there with her arms extended out you
know taking a picture with the pouty
lips in her hair all wet
and
I you know you know that overly used
expression like you know this marks the
beginning of the end of civilization as
we know it I hate when people say that
all right because nothing does it's a
gradual
decline
all right it's just another step but
that thing there If Ever I was gonna say
like I get really got I got depressed
when I look at it it makes me
it gives me this awful feeling when I
look at it I can't describe it it's just
like that I feel like there's a shift
in uh
just human behavior
I don't know what it is but
um Cleo relax it's fine you don't have
to eat anybody
it's a company
um sorry [__] dogs had its goddamn
ears up
um
so whenever I see it
the cut I always walk by and I always
turn it over because on the back there's
just writing of like you know I guess
recommendations out of all the selfie
books I'll tell you this one really I
just can't imagine
anybody has taken enough selfies that it
could fill up a [__] book and that
you would think that someone would want
to buy it and then somebody does and
then you're married to it
it's just it's it's
and my wife admits she goes I know I
know it's so bad it's so bad but I can't
look away I want like but this just I
think that feeds into the you know
wanting to be princesses and pretty and
dressing up and getting ideas on how to
[__] you know show off their tits in
a new [__] way I have no idea what it
is
but
um
I would say that that is I'm actually
getting depressed now I don't know if
you can hear my voice just talking about
it
like
more trees were cut down
it's like they're like a meeting like
okay you guys like which one of these
is gonna be the cover we have to figure
out what is worthy of the cover okay
which ones which is the Pharaoh like
they had to pick like like Pace it
like like which selfie goes on the cover
which is the first one that opens the
book which is the you know you want to
start strong
you know
the same way they get you tell we had to
tell a story with these photos like
there was [__] human beings sitting
there thinking about that [__]
and then they pitched the idea
and somebody said yes and then they made
it and then my wife bought it and it's
in my [__] house
and I swear to God
if if
it wouldn't do like major damage
to my relationship I would throw it in
the fireplace
[Laughter]
[Music]
I I and she's had it on the coffee table
she had it underneath the TV and she had
it downstairs on top of her dresser and
each time I [__] turned it over like
it was this bill that I didn't want to
deal with it and um I would say it's
that her music taste is on
[__] believable
and she truly is one of the greatest
people I've ever met that's why I
[__] married her but uh you know we
all got our stuff you know what I mean I
sit there and I watch sports and I
scream about it and I get mad and I I
I'm trying to be empathetic and saying
that that's just as [__] stupid
um
but I don't think it is I really don't
that [__] self-help book of selfies
not self-help whatever the [__] it is
was uh
I had to walk that one off
I had to really just be like okay yeah
we're married and this is this is
I know this isn't doesn't mean anything
about her but Jesus [__] Christ
it's more the influence of that like
that's going to influence somebody the
way when I saw great comedians I wanted
to be a comedian they'd like
I don't know I guess [__] need to be
inspired too right
that they're I want to be the next Kim
Kardashian I I gotta take start taking
[__] self-help self but I keep saying
self-help selfies
of myself
you know what I'm glad you asked me that
because I probably bummed all you guys
out
you know depressed you about all the
[__] uh the goddamn uh fishing out
the oceans so it serves me right that
you guys asked me a question that makes
me feel bad
um anyways getting married
Finance question
hey Billy Galaxy my lady and I are
getting married in two weeks good for
you man if you love her that's the
greatest [__] move you're ever gonna
make
um I never thought I'd say this I
actually love being married I like going
out doing my spots I like coming
directly home I like being in bed by 11.
it's [__] great now that I'm not
boozing I'm getting up I'm losing weight
I will tell you though oh my God
I'm only a weekend I drive by Billboards
and I just see a frosty [__] mug of
beer I'm just like dude I want 50 of
those
I want [__] 50 of those I'm one of
those guys I'm never gonna just not
drink
there's no [__] way I like it too
much
I'm not addicted to it I just [__]
love it
I can't wait for these [__] 72 days
to get over so I can [__] my liver up
again
[Music]
I [__] love it
and I and I am not ashamed
to say it you know I'm not slapping
around my wife I'm not screaming at
children
I get shit-faced in my own [__] Homer
I go out into a I'm a happy drunk
you know I'm a happy [__] drunk but
uh
it's it's really helping me to count
down the days rather than to go up so
because to me to sit there and think I'm
at day number seven
and I'm trying to get to 72 is [__]
brutal but if I look at it the other way
and it's like hey 65 more days for some
reason it's like when I'm on a treadmill
I'd rather count down from 60 Minutes
than start at one
I don't know why that's how my brain
works what are you gonna do for me so
anyway
what you do for me what are you gonna
what do you want from me I should have
said all right my lady and I are getting
married in two weeks all is great very
excited yada [__] yada
we both have good jobs each making about
125 Grand a year in Chicago you guys are
crushing it pay down your credit cards
save up your [__] money and buy
something that you can live in and kick
the [__] out of the principle all right
have your money work for you you earned
it it should work for you my question is
what advice do you have for us regarding
how to share in the finances moving
forward do we keep separate accounts one
joint account for bills maybe have Nia
weigh in on this
um
yeah I never did the joint account thing
if you're going to do the joint account
thing like you're really
um
you're really taking a risk there
because at any moment especially in the
Midwest
you know your partner can get addicted
to meth okay and don't even [__] roll
your eyes at me because I do Road gigs
and I know where the meth before and
after [__] Billboards are you get out
in the Midwest
and uh you know you drive through Iowa
you drive through Wyoming I know maybe
not in [__]
I don't know I I I think that I'm a I'm
a fan of um
separate accounts
because uh I understand money and I
don't blow it and I invest it as wisely
as I possibly can except for my drinking
habits and uh my
Hobbies but uh that would be up to you
it'd be up to my uh one of my one of my
relatives got married and uh he said
that was really freaky at first and then
then it was cool I don't think it's a
big deal
like I trust my wife to combine accounts
and all that type of [__] to be honest
with you we just have it you know what I
mean
uh but that's something that uh
that you guys should probably talk about
but I would say if she's not bringing it
up I wouldn't bring it up either
and if she does bring it up be like yeah
hey why don't we sit down and talk about
that
and just have a serious conversation
going like all right this is a
tremendous tremendous responsibility
for me
always put it on yourself so the
listener will actually listen
all right don't come at me hey [__]
[__] dick you know I don't want you
[__] spending my money don't look a
dump coming on now because they'll shut
down and get defensive you got to come
at them like this just be like this is a
huge responsibility I want you to know
this is a huge responsibility for me
which then she'll have to say well it's
a huge responsibility for me too right
you'll get her to say that you'll have
her on tape saying that and just say
listen
you know
as much as we're married and we're
combining our accounts I respect the
money that you're bringing into the
account and I want you to know that I
would never
like go out and buy
either something sizable or a bunch of
knickknacks that ended up being sizable
chunk out of the [__] account out of
respect for how hard you work
okay and really sit down and talk about
money talk about how you want to invest
it learn about money and all that type
of [__]
um so you don't end up like one of these
people who puts the money in there and
you think everything's [__] fine and
then there there
they got a credit card that they're
[__] lighting up and then they
attached your [__] I don't know what
it's One bank account and they go well
you got the money in there it's under
your name we want our 15 [__] Grand
and seven eight of that grand is yours
and that goes flying out the window
because she bought a bunch of blouses
and and shoes and this [__] can happen
all right and I'm speaking from the male
perspective because I am a guy and that
doesn't make me a sexist okay you know
I've been thinking a lot about these
[__] groups by the way
how dumb it is to to join a group and
why it's doomed for failure a lot of
times it's because once you join a group
that has a cause you basically go into
this Think Tank where everybody
basically shares the same point of view
so you don't have anybody keeping in
check on like well you know I don't know
about that or hey you know you insulted
them a little bit a little bit you
insulted them so it's like it becomes
like when two conspiracy theories meet
each other
and
you know conspiracy theorists need
somebody to be sitting there going like
dude do you really think or all right
dude you know I was with you till then
but if two conspiracy theorists meet
each other they just dude you know what
else oh yeah you know what I heard and
they just [__] they just go right
down the rabbit hole and I think a lot
of times why when I listen to like
a lot of the feminists complaining
it strikes me as funny because so much
of the [__] that they're bitching about
I relate to
it's like yeah that's happened to me
that has also happened to me 20 of it
yeah I'll go with it yeah that's [__]
up
you know but just know that even if you
got on par with guys you're still
staring at an 80 [__] over
that's the best I could give you
is that sexist if it is I don't give a
[__]
um
so anyways uh
I can't get over that Ford Galaxy man
that is exactly what the [__] I'm
looking for here's another great one
2500 bucks now he is two-door
let's see what we got here
oh geez there's a bunch of parts laying
around this is my [__] uh-oh
that tears oh I'll tell you it's a
little bit rough you know
that interior is too rough God damn it
what's the engine looking like
that's a hunk of [__]
all right hang on hang on hang on let me
get a look at the last one Jesus Christ
Andrew you crushed it with these
um all right this is is it really
interesting to have you guys looking at
listening to me looking at cars that you
can't [__] see
um here's another guy in 1998 a 68 sorry
a couple years off there
um
I don't know kind of get I'm gonna stick
with the 65 though
65 is badass
um here I go again I'm doing this [__]
again so anyways uh that's the podcast
for this week uh once again if you'd
like to donate to this podcast and uh 10
of the proceeds will go to the Saint
Jude Hospital is uh anytime you go on
Amazon just go to Amazon through my
website which is basically billboard.com
and you click on the merch page then you
click on the Amazon link it doesn't cost
you any extra money and and they just
kicked me a little bit of cash for uh
driving traffic their way
um other than that that is the podcast
for this week all right everybody you're
gonna lose three pounds a week with me
over the next eight weeks huh
get on the [__] scale today of course
it starts tomorrow how about that
Tuesday all right we'll start tomorrow
because you didn't know what was
happening right
so it starts tomorrow go to the grocery
store tonight you get your oatmeal you
get your bananas
your Apple your orange whatever the [__]
you want you get your turkey slices or
whatever [__] meat you want
um
you eat your [__] salads
one giant salad a day and then at night
just get that protein
even go vegan every once in a while at
night and then you know what take a walk
around the block you have no idea what
that would do hey Nia
hey really quickly uh somebody wanted
you to chime in on one of these [__]
questions
this is so stupid why would I do oh it
does well maybe maybe you can do it next
week
um
all right I'm not gonna ask you hey Cleo
watch out you're gonna shut the [__]
recorder off
all right
hey people ask me they said
they asked um of Nia's music what group
or band or genre do you have absolutely
no ability to swallow and I said none I
said you had this you have great taste
in music that you you're actually one of
those few people that you can put your
phone on shuffle at a party and you're
not embarrassed however sit down stop
trying to divide and conquer there you
go why well it's gonna work because the
one thing that I the one thing I can't
stomach what's that the Kim Kardashian
selfie book like the cover of that book
oh yeah no I got that book and I have no
shame I've participated in all levels of
Pop Culture so if anybody has something
to say
no I'm saying it nobody else is saying
you are saying it I I keep can you do me
a favor with that book what you can lay
it out anytime you want just just you
always turn it over yes have the cover
turned over because it depresses me why
I just I can't even put it into a
[__] like if you can't understand
because I just feel like there's this
now this this
I just hate her I just can't stand her
no I don't hate her but like why though
why are people so bothered because it's
like because they're like constantly
shove down our throats no the complete
narcissist oh yeah and the the fact that
I you know the six that whole [__]
famous for being famous you don't really
do anything you came into you [__]
sucked a dick you became famous the
family got behind it like yeah my
daughter sucks the best dick in [__]
Calabasas it wasn't quite like that but
okay
all right okay I'm sure they had an
honorable way of parlaying that whatever
whatever I'm trying not to be
judgmentally good for her she sucked a
dick she got famous now she's got a
selfie book and she's sitting there dude
it is just so it's like so I when I went
to get it I was surprised that it was
sold out at this very independent and a
hip section of La it was sold out they
were like oh it's sold out as soon as we
got it this has nothing to do with other
people this has to do with me oh this is
about you I'm sorry go on just saying
you asked me why it depresses me those
[__] people when I watch somebody
take a selfie rather than just look I
you stand from the Hollywood Sign you
click on whatever but when people hold
it up over their head and then they're
turning their head trying to [__]
look better looking than they are and
sticking your lips out the duck lips is
bad but why wouldn't you try to look as
good as possible in a picture that
you're taking of yourself that's what's
so great about the selfie is that you
can really see what angle looks best and
what the lighting is I think it's it's
it makes a lot of sense thanks
logically to me it's it makes perfect
sense to adjust yourself before you just
take a picture just just like that no I
want to make sure that I'm looking right
that's the whole point
why are you why do you look confused
I am old enough to know that I am not
going to convince you otherwise
so
God bless you and in the Selfies just
just do me you can can we have a
compromise you just turn the book over I
will just keep it somewhere where it's
not and your line of vision since you're
so offended by it I'm not offended by it
it just it depresses me to look at it
well I don't want to depress you
um I don't be condescending just okay go
on just just get out of here no I'm just
I won't I'll keep it out of your sight
I'll keep it out of your sight okay are
you writing that down right now no no no
no
for you do you want to tell the the
caffeinated not the caffeinated story I
I would can we save that for uh just
checking in on you yes because I gotta
go okay get out of here because I gotta
wrap this up and the internet sucks here
and this will take me four hours to
[__] upload
um all right that's the podcast for this
week on Thursday I will tell you guys
the story of the uh
decaffeinated not decaffeinated
uh you know I [__] up
I [__] up getting this tea with my
wife and she's and she tried to say I
wasn't listening and I actually was
listening but I thought
decaffeinated not to caffeinated I
thought that that's what the two flavors
were
um
but it's a long [__] story all right
that was confusing that's the podcast
for this week go [__] yourselves and uh
God bless all of you go take some
selfies you know put out your [__]
Union do the little peace sign too like
whatever that's for
you know
like you're out
even though you're not in my life
um I know I'm just a crabby old man now
go [__] yourselves I'll talk to you I'll
check in on you dirty